what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
alright so picking up with Spider Island
part 2 I know a lot of people are going
to be like no clutch hangers with a good
thing is that this video came out within
hours of the last video so don't be
giving me no hard times about
cliffhangers don't be giving me a hard
time about no quit things so what we end
up doing what we end up doing here is we
basically pick up kind of continuing
where we left off we join Mary Jane
Watson facing off against some of these
guys but also using her using around
letting her own spider abilities but the
cool thing about this is that you know
within our Lady of Saints Church where
these individuals were hanging out again
they were just kind of left there when
agent venom was able to succeed in
defeating antivenom Mary Jane Watson
begins to gain a better understanding of
what it means to be spider-man and
that's one of the interesting things
about this is because this never really
seemed to be a concept that was explored
this because the fact that I'm not aware
of Mary Jane Watson ever having spider
powers on this level instead before the
events of one more day and even after
the events of one more day where she
still knew the identity of Peter Parker
the only real exposure she had to what
it meant to be spider-man was basically
the told it would take on Peter Parker
having to walk the knife's edge of
keeping his identity secret while
simultaneously trying to make sure that
he could be an effective hero and so
because of this she's coming to it from
the other side of the coin she's seen
what it means having to pull her punches
you know facing off against a lot of
these these giant spiders recognizing
that they're people at the same time and
they could possibly be cured and so as
her realized that she basically has to
stop these spiders from killing those
humans that have enjoyed that haven't
mediated while simultaneously not
killing the spiders and so again it's
this very interesting situation because
she has to kind of be a savior and a and
and not a killer at the same time that
that makes any sense but again we also
end up joining with the Queen the reason
why is because of the fact that Reed
Richards is using this cure on son John
remember so Johnny is basically a member
of a horizon labs one of the people who
is infected but almost immediately after
this cure begins to develop after almost
immediately after it's derived the Queen
begins to start going through all these
individuals who have this this insect
gene by way of this Potter Island virus
and eventually is able to happen
- Johnny what she realizes so johnny is
in horizon lives and Reed Richards and
his team has synthesized a cure and so
using said Johnny she basically kind of
forces the physical mutation and the
result is that so Johnny kind of gets
out of control for a second but it's
almost immediately subdued by a
combination of Jessica drew spider woman
and Reed Richards himself now with
regards to the injection of this cure
this is when the Queen starts to realize
that this cure is legitimate and that if
it's mass-produced if it turns like an
aerosol if it goes airborne it'll
literally take away everything that
Queens been working for all of her power
will basically be gone and so what
happens is jackal Sims came on a mission
to Horizon lives for the purpose of
basically contaminating this cure making
sure that it can never go into
full-blown use now at this point what we
also do is we basically join the man in
the sixth rim we only get a glimpse here
but we joined a man in the sixth room
this unknown third individual who was
helpful and basically creating a cure by
way of Reed Richards and max Modell and
what we end up finding out is that this
third man is Michael Morbius now Michael
Morbius being rolled into this story is
not an accident remember prior to
Michael Morbius you know gaining his
infection becoming a living vampire he
was a Nobel winning biochemist and so
he's really like one of the best people
that you would want he's really one of
the top minds when it comes to
biochemistry when it comes to biological
contaminant when it comes to creating a
cure for virtually anything the other
half of this is a Michael Morbius who's
always tried to find a way to cure
himself as it would creates a really
interesting situation because it's kind
of Michael Morbius offering some measure
of atonement in addition to this Michael
Morbius is just a fan favorite so why
not have him in the story he'll like it
it just works it it's really cool to see
him there I'm sure a lot of fans just
like yeah Michael Morbius we don't get
to see a lot of them but we get to see
enough of him here now of course the
other funny thing is that we also end up
joining Madame web Julia carpenter who
like appears to Reed Richards and is
like you put these inhibitors
around the city of New York take them
down and then she leaves and that's it
she she doesn't she's like shows up
she's like fix it now and it just leaves
and it's kind of funny this is like this
quick little pop-up situation here but
what this does is it allows Dan Slott to
begin segue into the final act of this
story and what I mean here is that we're
these psychic blocks were put in place
for the purpose of basically removing
people's ability to leave the city of
New York one is up happening is that
witness the spectacle hibbett ER
our lives kind of has to play this
balancing act they have to sit down they
have to say okay fine look we cannot
take down the toxic inhibitors in their
entirety because if believe if we do
this infection will spread we have a
cure but if they just scatter to the
four corners of the world well suddenly
we're stretched too thin and there's no
stopping this contagion but if we keep
it here in New York then it's easier to
control it's easier to cure and so what
happens is horizon labs uses some of the
knowledge of Peter Parker that he had
given them over the course of his
experience and they basically kind of
modify the signal to send it out in a
way that basically restores Peter
Parker's spider sense now with regards
to the restoration of Peter Parker
spider since this coincides with his
conflict with Caine and the reason why
is because the jackal had sent Kane to
Horizon lab so the purpose of
contaminating this cure and so in Peter
Parker had traveled back to horizon labs
he was basically forced to face off
against Kane now again this is mutated
this is Kane all kinds of screwed up the
full fruition of where his character was
going to be because of his unstable
genes and so because of this during the
conflict when Peter Parker's what is
what a spider since is restored to him
the result is they able to basically
outwit and outmaneuver Cain and
virtually every feasible sense and this
is one of the reasons why it works is
because Cain has you know he's stronger
he's faster he's more durable than
spider-man but spider-man basically is
able to use his way of the spider
kung-fu
in conjunction with his spider sense and
make himself virtually untouchable now
none of this really matters just because
of the fact Peter Parker basically sins
came flying into the VAT of anti-venom
you know and essentially just kind of
cures him and returns them to his normal
appearance but what Dan Slott was doing
with this was basically saying this
whole nonsense about Cain being like a
weird physical spider thing this has
gone far enough
like we need to weed either like well
pardon my language we need a priori to
get off a con like we got to do
something with it and so Dan Slott like
what is going to basically send him off
like what we're going to do is we're
going to send him off to the cornfield
he's going to be Scout spider but in
order for us to pull that off what we
need to do is cure him we need to
basically make his make his body
physically perfect so that instead of
having these corrupted genes way he did
you know it's part of a part of Clone
Saga that instead what he's going to do
is he's going to have basically
perfected genes is literally what's
going to happen here now what we end up
doing is we end up finding out that
because of the fact that this signal has
been modified that is restores the
spider sense of Peter Parker Dan Slott
begins to draw on the web of life and
destiny because keep in mind when the
River bison destiny was introduced in
comics it was modifying spider-man's
mythos prior to that point it was always
believed that spider-man's powers his
strength agility speed you know spiders
things so on and so forth all those just
came from just the radiation and his
blood the web of life and destiny said
no that's not the case Peter Parker is
basically an avatar he he more or less
is a character that reflects kind of a
representation of these totems you know
the he's basically uh I guess a herald
of the web and lights and definitely a
destiny of that makes any sense
all it really means is that he derives
his powers directly from the web of life
and destiny well so does the Queen and
so does Madame web and so by giving
Peter Parker his spider-sense back the
Queen now has full access to her
abilities and Madame web has full access
to her abilities but we also find out is
that this giant weird spider monster
could appeared at the beginning of the
story with Steve Rogers that Steve
Rogers had been taken by jackal he had
been mutated and turned into a servant
of the Queen of course he had since been
turned back but the idea here is that
he's basically kind of this last man
standing trying to face off against to
clean herself and bring her rule down
the issue with this is that with the
Queen having full access to her powers
she goes into her full form and what she
becomes is an omega-level threat now
this is something that I want to draw
your attention to because in Marvel
Comics when it comes to the idea of like
omega-level mutant Omega level threat
this is how they're confirmed for
example we saw in like an uncanny x-men
apartment and forty nights posted about
this on Twitter we saw that Emma Fox was
confirmed as an omega-level mutant and
x-men vol 2 issue numbers 70 or
something like that Charles Xavier was
confirmed to be an alpha level mutant
these are how things end up playing out
that there's individuals whose status
within the Marvel community is confirmed
now when it comes to like Omega level
threats those are basically people that
have the power of Omega level mutants
but they're not mutants that's all that
means that's the only difference it's
just kind of an interchangeable term but
the idea is that we also have Peter
Parker trying to maintain this ruse that
he and spider-man are two distinctly
different individuals because remember
in the mind of Peter Parker he hasn't
revealed his identity to anybody yet no
one knows who he is
and so to the eyes of everybody except
for like Reed Richards and a handful of
others that don't that know his secret
identity when they see Kayne Parker
walking around in the spider-man costume
while simultaneously seeing him standing
alongside Peter Parker what do they have
no reason to believe that Peter Parker
and spider-man are one on the same is
basically Peter's ruse this was his way
of kind of clear in the air whenever
money with horizon lives there at sm say
hey look guys do you like me and
spider-man are two distinctly different
people and so because of this we
basically pick up what kind of like this
flash man battle I mean you have really
you know you have like Kayne Parker you
have to go yeah Peter Parker you have
all these guys that are facing off
against you know against a clean fighter
but what is up happening is Peter Parker
begins to draw on what it was that
outsourced myself you have all the
resources that you need in order to take
down all these different spiders and the
cream all you have to do is harness them
effectively and that's when Peter
recalls back to the octobots of Doctor
Octopus the Doctor Octopus would use a
helmet to control all these little
individual BOTS Peter Parker races back
to the precinct alongside Mary Jane
Watson puts the helmet on and begin
using all these different octobots for
the purpose of trying to take out the
Queen and all these other individuals
who are infected with this virus the
problem with this is this queen is
wildly powerful in terms of her
abilities and so when is not happening
here is it basically end up seeing Kane
doing what needs to be done where Peter
Parker has this moral code and Peter
Parker says we do not kill
we need to incapacitate her Wayne to
take her out and then take her prisoner
Cain says no the only way that we can
deal with this is to take this woman out
it's to eliminate her inner entirety and
that's what damn thoughts drawing on
here with the idea of Cain because
remember going all the way back to Clone
Saga when he first showed up Cain was
designed to beat his character who was a
moral he wasn't really a good guy he
wasn't really a bad guy
he had his own moral compass he would
kill if he needed to he would save
people if he needed to he was willing to
go further than Peter Parker was and so
what happens as the story basically
comes to a close is that Cain White's
out this Spider Queen basically
eliminates her in her entirety and so
with the entire spider spider I own have
been kind of winding down The Cure's
basically simplifies its mass
distributed to everybody to the point
that everybody kind of begins to line
down from their infection and so what
this does is this leads into the
epilogue of Spider Island which begins
to wrap up all these loose ends it's Dan
Slott going through and say okay here's
where we stand with a Spider Man mythos
going forward after the events of Spider
Island but with that being said guys
we're going to bring this video to an
end if you are new here the comics
explain make sure you guys with the sub
button become part of the wild core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah because the
next big event after this is superior
spider-man probably the best fighter man
story out of arrest I love soup
spider-man Doctor Octopus in the body of
Peter Parker it's amazing
lady why guys we're gonna bring this to
an end and catch you all later
[Music]
[Applause]
you